well it's the middle of January means a
lot of people are making goals for their
money right now and there's a couple
types of strategies that you need for
your money if you're gonna win
you need to have offense and you need to
have defense just like a good football
game offense is creating the budget
building your emergency fund paying off
your debt most people forget about the
defense though and that's insurance now
insurance most of us hate insurance it
just feels like I'm just throwing money
out the window the car driving along the
interstate most people just don't and
but we know we need it because if man if
you don't have it when something happens
boom you got a mess you don't have
health insurance you got a mess right
you know I'm car insurance you wreck
your car it's something you got a mess
and so on so it's not there to make you
wealthy but insurance is there to
transfer risk it's there to protect your
money and you don't feel like you're
getting any traction and some of the
insurance agents out there agree with me
on the stuff I teach some of them don't
agree with me on what I teach but that
would be just the guys that are wrong so
let's start with some basics you do need
life insurance if you have a family that
depends on your income term life
insurance you do need health insurance
every one needs health insurance had a
guy call the other day he had fifty six
thousand dollars in medical bills
and his calm I said why didn't you have
health insurance I couldn't afford it I
said you couldn't afford to be without
it cost you fifty six thousand dollars
yeah I know that now
yeah that's the deal so you need health
insurance obviously you need auto
insurance obviously you need homeowner's
insurance which covers your home now a
lot of people rent and don't have
renter's insurance your landlord does
not have cannot have coverage on your
stuff they do not have an insurable
interest you have to cover a contents
policy when you're the tenant
and it's absolutely vital it's very
inexpensive you need to get that
long-term disability insurance
everyone needs that and identity theft
protection and those that are over 60
need to look at long-term care insurance
so with some of these you can get your
costs way down when you get your
emergency fund fully funded
I carry a $5,000 deductible on my cars
well I Drive expensive cars that are
nice and paid for but that keeps my
premiums way down some of you are
carrying a $250 deductible on your car
if you'd raise that to a thousand you'd
see your premiums drop dramatically now
when you do that if you go from 250 to a
thousand you are picking up a an extra
seven hundred and fifty dollars in risk
and so if that cuts your premiums by
seventy five dollars a year that means
you have to drive for ten years and not
ever act not likely depend on where you
live right well I don't know Tareq I
know but you're probably over two so the
thing you know people run into you run
into people stuff happens and so here's
the thing if you take a $750 extra risk
though and it saves you $300 a year well
that's like two years and you've got
your money back right so you need to do
that now if you are starting to build
some assets you're heading towards
everyday millionaire status you're
starting to have some money you need to
look at an umbrella policy a couple of
hundred bucks to 300 bucks a year you
can get an extra million dollars in
umbrella coverage for liability on your
car homeowners insurance and it's just
$253 a year in most areas and it gets
really really a good idea I carry a ten
million dollar umbrella policy on me
because if I bump into somebody they
grab their back and go god Dave Ramsey
hit me I'm cashing in right and so I've
got out you know I it's just the way it
is out there people so you deal now what
you don't want to do is the gimmick
insurances you want to avoid accident
insurance and accidental death insurance
listen if you die
you're dead that's how that works it
doesn't matter how you die you can be
walking across the parking lot and get
hit by a car you can be walking across
the parking lot and die of a heart
attack you're still dead both ways your
family still needs to replace your
income and the exact same amount
regardless of the cause of your death
you're not like double dead if you die
by accident and so I'll get twice as
much of it died by accident then more
likely to die by accident that statement
says I think I'm beating the insurance
company at their game you're not if some
if insurance is cheap it's because
there's a very low likelihood of the
thing occurring because they don't lose
money they know what they're doing so
you don't need twice as much insurance
when you die by an accident you don't
need cancer insurance big gimmick
insurance a lot of people buy cancer
insurance you have health insurance
it covers cancer if it doesn't you need
different health insurance you don't
need heart attack insurance because your
health insurance covers heart attacks
you don't need kidney stone insurance
because your health insurance covers
kidney stones or it should okay
and to my knowledge they're not offering
kidney stone insurance but it could
happen you never know
you don't need cellphone insurance if
you cannot afford to replace your cell
phone you shouldn't buy one this is an
inexpensive item seriously comparatively
speaking
don't buy extended warranties and other
kind of insurance they're all about the
profit seventy-five to eighty percent of
what you pay for those extended
warranties is profit just and marketing
costs just stay away from it absolutely
a bad idea you don't need mortgage life
insurance that pays off your mortgage if
you die it's five times more expensive
than term insurance so if you have a
$200,000 mortgage go buy 200,000 our
term policy or buy 10 to 12 times your
income on you which would pay off your
house likely almost always and so you
need to have term insurance in place to
do that
and I catch a lot of crap for this these
days because but there's because there's
such a craze over pets I love pets I
love my dogs I cry like a girl
every time they die I love my dogs my
shih tzu was in my lap in front of the
fireplace drinking coffee with me this
morning he wasn't ringing coffee I was
but it'd be a bad idea for that
I'll drink coffee but yeah I love them I
am NOT spending $10,000 to keep a dog
alive it's a dog I'm maybe that's old
school
but you pet lovers think I'm heartless
I'm a pet lover too but it's a dog now
if you've got tens of millions of
dollars and you want to spend ten
thousand dollars to keep a dog alive
that's fine but I'm not doing it I'm not
spending ten thousand dollars to keep a
cat alive for sure cats are just well
anyone yeah
so whatever I mean you don't need to
spend money for chemo on your parakeet
okay I'm sorry I know that hurts some of
your feelings I know some of you have
gotten your lives twisted up about this
stuff but pet health insurance I don't
buy it if you can't afford to spend a
certain amount of money on the dog or
the cat to keep it alive and keep it
well maintained then you shouldn't have
a pet and then you put need to put a
limit on the value of this pets life all
that you soon sue mean I know it sounds
so mean but I'm just like what's known
as a grown-up and so I have to address
these situations and you guys got to the
side you can decide and if you want to
spend a bazillion dollars to keep your
puppy alive three more weeks that's fine
you can do that I ain't doing it
I love the puppies and they go to puppy
heaven and it's all good life goes on
I've you know I've outlived a whole
bunch of them by now I've had ten dogs
in my life so far and I'll probably have
about ten more for
gone I love them but I outlive them and
so you got to think about this stuff so
be aware the gimmick insurance is out
there but be sure you have good defence
term insurance health insurance auto
insurance homeowners insurance long-term
disability insurance
identity theft may be an umbrella policy
if you want to get a five minute checkup
and make sure you got the right coverage
is done it's really easy to do all you
just do is text check up 233 789 text
check up 233 789